et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Olivier fort bonjour
Voilà députée de Seine-et-Marne premier
secrétaire du Parti socialiste on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représentée par Fabrice
vaisser Redon du groupe Ebra bonjour
Fabrice Oriane bonjour Olivier
fort le président de la République qui
prendra donc la parole ce soir à 20h
est-ce que vous en attendez quelque
chose
je crois que le président a tout fait
pour que l'on attend de rien du tout de
son allocution il a tout fait pour que
le lien soit rompu il est face à un pays
qu'il a lui-même fracturé et on sait
bien qu'il est capable à l'oral de nous
faire les plus grands discours on se
souvient de ces discours pendant la
période du confinement mais ce sont
précisément ces femmes et ces hommes
qu'il a lui-même félicité applaudi comme
nous tous à 20h qui sont aujourd'hui les
principales victimes de la réforme qu'il
a engagée et donc
il pourra nous dire ce qu'il veut en
fait vous savez vous connaissez cette
formule sur l'amour en fait il y a pas
d'amour il y a des preuves d'amour et je
pense que le président a besoin de
donner des preuves au peuple français
qui les entend ce week-end j'étais en ma
circonscription
[Musique]
pour nous dire que il est très heureux
de ce qu'il a fait qu'il va continuer et
qu'on passe à la chose enfin qu'on passe
à la suite mais je crois qu'il n'a pas
compris il n'a pas compris qu'il n'y a
pas de suite possible sans revenir sur
la réforme des retraites il y a un
risque que ce soit contre-productif que
ce soit
[Musique]